so did you have you seen that this clip
is going around uh this is a Troy Bond I
I don't know who he is he's he's up and
coming comic about 22 000 subscribers
but this is going viral
um so apparently he's doing a set it's
worth watching the whole thing because
it's funny but a black woman up front
calls him racist okay here's how it
starts
[Applause]
way better than the last show I just did
they were all pieces of [ __ ] okay let's
go off to a good start opener
and then sometimes you don't get a good
crowd sometimes
you get a good crowd
they're not great this is good
like this crowd feels feels great but
it's it's gonna get good
I feel like I'm one bad joke away from
this feeling like a
like a public pool
First Choice to swim but it's a pool
[Laughter]
you can be the Band-Aid you swim away
from this is gonna be a fun night
look at this room tonight look how we're
all together in this room getting a new
covert variant
don't you feel closer together knowing
because comedy brings people together
that's why this almost feels like if if
Pete Davidson was funny
what was the joke one of you said uh
Pete Davidson uh he said Pete Davidson
if his dad didn't die in 911.
which one of you said that I was one of
you one of these [ __ ] idiots yeah I
think that was virgin yeah
if he actually had a father to get a
good sense of humor from
forces do stand-up if any politician
just stand up in history they could have
avoided controversy I voted for Joe
Biden but that [ __ ] didn't feel great
okay that's pretty funny right
[Laughter]
felt like I was giving Grandpa the keys
to the Oldsmobile
and telling him to drive to California
that was the best of a bad situation
I give credit where credit is due I'm
probably the most Pro anti-trump comic
out there that month shut the [ __ ] up
oh boy that's a white guy trying to talk
to black people I'm not by the way you
saw he hasn't talked he hasn't mentioned
anybody he said nothing yeah as a white
guy trying to talk to black people no
you're not yes I wasn't no you were you
just tuned in
you were trying to for what what are you
upset about it's not me
no and shut up any black person I've
tried to laugh at his [ __ ] jokes by
the way whenever whenever you're
whenever you're turning to the rest of
the audience and going no shut up yeah
yeah it's not like everybody's on your
side here God women just get this
confidence black person never tried to
laugh at his [ __ ] jokes no stop
having fun [ __ ]
laughs
having fun can we get her
[Music]
yeah that's what happens you talk about
no my probation officer is here now
I don't know who the [ __ ] you're mad at
but it's not me
I'm a person trying to make fun of black
people see now you're crying and I was
just trying to make you laugh
what's up
tricks work on him
now I'm gonna make fun I was trying to
be empathetic it wasn't funny it was not
cool
how dare I add a comedy clue
she came here for a TED talk
everybody knows you go to the basement
for political opinion
I don't even know what he's saying but
it's just [ __ ] sounds tense
why do you think I'm doing this for a
living you think I was a football player
I'm a [ __ ] go ahead
there's nothing you can say to me I
haven't said six inches from the mirror
[Laughter]
bro that is a good line brilliant line
that's a good I've done that to her yeah
you're the first name going in my
suicide note tonight
yeah
have a good night Kamala Harris